this is facebook home on the htc first
facebook home is facebook's android
takeover it's not quite an os but it's
much more than an app we're calling it
an operating system facebook home
launches when your phone turns on the
cover feed shows full screen images with
stories from your news feed it's a
visually immersive experience a little
icon of your profile picture rests at
the bottom of the screen and you can use
it to navigate through the phone
scrolling through cover feed is quick
you can also double tap to like a story
and tap the comments icon to leave
comments
it's a much more tactile experience than
just scrolling through a long list of
updates
but the best part about facebook home is
chat heads you don't have to go into
another app to message friends their
chat heads just hover above whatever
else you're doing
you can move them around or toss them
away when you're done
facebook home doesn't invade your
android apps
instagram comes pre-installed on htc
first but you also still get chrome
google maps the play store and more
which you can all find in the app
launcher
there you'll also be able to post
updates photos and location to facebook
facebook home still needs a lot of
polish and a lot more work but overall
it shows that facebook is finally
getting mobile right